from phrases dripping with emotion to
trinkets imbued with deep meaning there
are plenty of seemingly small things
with big implications in the second part
of The Witcher season 3. the world of
The Witcher features many different
groups all with their own unique history
cultures and allegiances so audiences
could this could be forgiven for
sometimes having difficulty tracking
them all one of the groups that have
risen to prominence in season 3 is a
scoyatel army a group of Elven Fighters
LED at least the first by the warrior
Gallatin played by series newcomer
Robbie Amal the square Hotel work
alongside Francesca finder bear the
queen of the elves although her
obsession with capturing Siri puts
Francesca at odds with Gallatin while
this Army of skilled Warriors officially
goes by the name scoyatel viewers might
notice that they are often referred to
as screw us the nickname might seem
strange at first but its meaning comes
from The Witcher novels particularly
Blood of Elves in the novels a square
hotel or a group of Fighters consisting
primarily of elves with some dwarves and
halflings who aim to ensure freedom and
safety in the northern kingdoms for all
non-human races the word scoyotel
translates to squirrel in Elder speech a
name they were given for their tendency
to wear scroll tails on their hats the
sixth episode of the third season is
packed with shocking moments bound to
leave fans gasping one such moment takes
place after nilfgaardian troops managed
to Steed themselves into aratuza and
begin attacking the Mages who were there
for the conclave the Mages refused to go
down without a fight though several of
them including tasaya and notorious
erect a magical barrier to Halt and
onslaught of arrows coming in their
Direction unfortunately the move does
nothing to slow the arrows which Pierce
right through the magical wall and kill
several Mages including Artorias to
Sayer is quick to note that the arrows
were tipped with demeritium in the
universe of The Witcher that's a unique
type of metal known to suppress magical
abilities since the arrowheads are
coated with demeritium they're able to
pass through the magical barrier with
these even though that same barrier can
stop most other materials this scene
actually isn't even the first time
demeritium is used in the episode
earlier sigismund dijkstra the radanian
spymaster uses handcuffs made of
demeritium to hold vilgaforce and his
followers captive Gamers may also
recognize a fictional metal from the
video game The Witcher 3 while the ore
is a collectible crafting material used
to make special gear
the Wizard's Dragon Ball wasn't exactly
a sympathetic character throughout his
free season run on The Witcher he was
greedy manipulative and had a
deep-seated hatred towards elves and
students with Elven blood but in his
final moments he willingly sacrifices
himself using the all-consuming Fire
magic to help protect the Mages of
oratuza by destroying a large force of
Elven and an elf Guardian Invaders his
final words to The Elven Invaders
waiting for
it not only highlight the character's
long-standing Prejudice towards elves
but also hints at the important role
that falka will play in the final two
episodes of the season
following the events of the battle Siri
begins to see a hooded figure who both
taunts her and gives her advice on
Surviving viewers of The Witcher blood
origin might immediately recognize the
voice as that of falca a revolutionary
with Elven blood known for her violent
nature Strega bore actually fought
during falca's rebellion and ended up
losing both of his hands using Illusions
to make it appear as if he still had
them the line also ties back to Strega
Ball's history of obsessing over curses
Falco was famous for the curse you
placed on those that killed her some of
it makes sense that she would be a
fixation of stregabore who also had a
fascination with the famous Curse of the
Black Sun
the seventh episode of the season is
unique in that it focuses almost
entirely on Siri with only brief
glimpses of geralt Rivia the episode
picks up in the aftermath of the battle
of thaned which ended with Siri
destroying tool Lara also known as the
Tower of the girl and being sent through
the portal inside unfortunately for Siri
the unstable portal teleports her into
the sky over an arid stretch of
inhospitable desert a student of
geography Siri notes that mausak used to
refer to this place as a frying pan in
the universe of The Witcher the frying
pan is a nickname given to the korath
desert a large sea of arid sand dunes
with few living inhabitants akoroth
desert is far to the south of the
northern kingdoms where the majority of
the story of The Witcher takes place it
also lies to the east of nilfgaard the
Kingdom Under the role of Siri's father
Emir while nilfgaard has no control over
the neighboring desert it is still the
closest geographically that Siri has
been to her father's Kingdom in all
three seasons
it's no secret that yaskir is a fun
favorite character and his interactions
with his fellow leads are among the
funniest in the show
after spending time bonding with geralt
in season 1 and yennefer in season 2 the
third season of The Witcher finally
gives yaskia some valuable time with
Siri building the relationship between
the two this leads to several comedic
scenes including a particular standout
in the fourth episode while garevalt and
Jennifer speak alone Siri and yaskia
watch from the bushes nearby and to make
up their own dialogue for the
conversation when geralt and Jennifer
finally kiss yaskia jokes is there a
unicorn nearby by any chance at first as
quick appears just to be yucky a sense
of humor but it's actually the show's
clever way of subtly foreshadowing an
important character that Siri meets
later in the season after being
teleported to the korath desert Siri is
alone and forced to survive with only
what she has on her luckily she happens
across a nearby unicorn whom she
nicknames little horse the two help each
other survive and she even rescues him
from a sand monster after little horses
poisoned she heals him by tapping into
Fire magic the Unicorn becomes afraid of
her and runs away leaving Siri alone
once again
during his climactic fight with
vilgefort geralt is grievously injured
and near death his back is broken by the
traitorous Mage leaving him unable to
walk luckily geralt has brought to
broccolon Forest the home of the dryads
which viewers may remember from the
Show's first season while Geralds has
brought inside as a friend to the dryads
access to the forest is forbidden to
most Outsiders this becomes an issue
when yaskia comes to the forest hoping
to see geralt he's denied entry but the
tricky Bard has an idea that will help
the dryads see that he's a friend he
begins to sing a beautiful song in Elder
speaks at the dryads call Enchanted
flowers readers of The Witcher books
might recognize this song by another
name Elaine atario an Elven ballad that
appears in time of contempt the novel
that is a basis for season three The
Ballad tells the story of an Elven
heroine named atario who gives a writer
of the song a beautiful and Enchanted
flower after they fall deeply in love
with her in the book Elaine atario
translates to atario the beautiful ra
other than Enchanted flowers players of
the first Witcher video game may also
recognize a song from the remix version
in the game's fourth chapter
Garrett may be the only familiar facer
yaskia sees after entering broccolon
Forest but viewers will recognize
another character series Elven friend
Dara after passing way to Siri Dara
becomes a spy for dijkstra and Philippa
eilhart he initially joins Francesca's
elves to gain information but then
chooses to really support their cause
after Squire Taylor side to side with
the White Flame Dara makes his way to
Brooklyn forest with several other
refugees Osmond Lee deciding to stay
with the dryads to avoid future violence
this isn't the first time that Dara has
been to Brooklyn forest in season 1 he
and Siri find their way there while on
the run from nilfgaard after being shot
by one of the dryads Dara is healed and
made to drink the Waters of broccolon
which will kill anyone with evil intent
toward the forest for those pure of
heart and drinking the waters will help
them numb their pain and eventually
forget their troubles Dara is happy with
broccolon and wishes to stay but after
Serious Force to leave he follows her
out of broccoline so it makes sense in
one to return
in The Season's eighth episode tasaya
unable to cope with the loss of aratuza
and rat with guilt sadly chooses to take
her own life not only is to Saya one of
the most important characters to die so
far on The Witcher but her death also
has a major impact on Jennifer who views
her teacher and Mentor like a mother
losing to Saya is also a major blow to
the remaining sorceresses but it also
helps unite them in a common cause to
say his death scene fittingly includes
several callbacks to the beginning of
her relationship with Jennifer whom she
addresses in a final letter she refers
to Jennifer as Piglet a nickname that
she used for the young sorceress back
when she was a student aratuza and has
rarely used since she also writes
referring to one of her early lessons
for Yan sometimes a flower is just a
flower and the best thing it can do for
us is die she also takes her life by
slashing her wrists the same fate from
which she saved Jennifer years earlier
it takes time for Jennifer to visit
geralt in Brooklyn Forest after he's
injured fighting vilgefort once she does
arrive their scene together is very
sweet she apologizes for not visiting
him earlier and brings up bad news that
she wasn't able to recover Siri geralt
acknowledges that yeniffer must leave to
help the remaining sorceresses and that
it is his job to recover Siri
at the end of their conversation
Jennifer says
[Music]
this may be a nod to the behind the
scenes issues rather than Fiction
with several seasons to go geralt and
Jennifer will undoubtedly see each other
again but it is the last time Anya
chalotra and Henry Cavill will share the
screen as these characters when they
next to me to geralt will be played by
actor Liam Hemsworth who is taking up
the mantle of geralt of Rivia following
Henry cavill's departure from the show
Henry cavill's final scene is geralt is
certainly a memorable one now seeing
yaskia looked to think past the day of
Guardian checkpoint geralts offers an
expensive pendant as a bribe to a guard
yaskia tells him not to give it up
knowing how much it means to him but
geralt lets it go anyway an elf Guardian
Soldier lets them through but geralt
turns back after seeing a group of elves
in trouble he slays all of the soldiers
but won while he no longer needs the
bribe to get past the checkpoint he
still chooses to leave the pendant that
pendant belonged to renfree a princess
geralt fell in love with in the series
first episode he eventually had to kill
renfree to save the town and he never
forgave himself for her death he held
onto her pendant as a reminder of his
feelings as well as his own perceived
failure to save her giving up the
pendant and willfully leaving it behind
shows that geralt has finally moved on
it's a perfect link from Henry cavill's
first episode to his last and maybe a
nod to a girl's entering a new chapter
of his life
the phrase Never Last always found as
one that viewers will hear quite a few
times throughout the third season of The
Witcher the in-universe explanation has
to do with serious Talisman which
Jennifer uses to place a locator spell
that Siri can deploy to help geralt find
her whenever she is lost she utters the
phrase and geralt and Jennifer are drawn
to her the phrase of course is much more
than just some magic words to activate
the locator spell it's more or less the
theme of the entire season and in some
ways the series while series spend
pretty much the entirety of season 2 by
geralt's side season 3 splits the two up
far more often Siri is regularly
separated from geralt and Jennifer and
often has to use a locator spell to
bring them back together she also
mentions hyena fur that the only thing
she really cares about is that the three
of them stick together by the time the
season raps Siri has once again been
separated from a found family taking
honor foreboding identity
but garrels assures yasuke that he will
find Siri at any cost
showing the audience that the theme of
neverlust always found will continue in
the seasons to come
foreign
[Music]